you
good afternoon from Brussels and welcome
to the live chat with the European
Commissioner for transport
mrs. Adina Berlin Commissioner welcome
to the studio thank you for inviting me
safe travels summer 2020 this is the
title of today's citizens dialogue which
we are doing it we are doing online
after the spring we had everybody wants
to travel now and either for leisure
seeing family reuniting family even we
need to travel safely because as you
said in many occasions until we don't
find a vaccine that is widely available
for coronavirus we have to learn to live
and travel with it we have received a
lot of questions about how travel safe
this summer in Europe not only in Europe
since we started advertising this this
live chat with you
we also gonna take some live questions
as we are obviously live on the Facebook
and Twitter of the European Commission
so as I said a lot of questions with
your permission I'll start with the
first one I don't Facebook is asking
what is the Commission doing to ensure
that the rights of passengers are being
applied to everyone well I'm from the
very beginning of this crisis this was
an issue and we were were very firm in
reaffirming the right of passengers to
be respected in terms of travel and also
for travel packages we restated this we
insisted upon and also when the company
airline companies face it liquidity
problems we step in and help them in
other ways so let me remind everyone
that the passengers are entitled to
reimbursement if they wish for a
canceled flight and a company can
propose a voucher but
the passenger has the rights to accept
it or not and also we issued some
recommendations to the Member States
national authorities how to make the
vultures more attractive for people to
opt for a voucher that means for example
the voucher to be insured against the
insolvency of a company or the company
can made a motor more attractive
offering more money or a more attractive
service instead of the one which was
canceled so there are ways for those who
accept a voucher to have an attractive
culture but their right to be reimbursed
remains remains by law in European Union
if this right is not respected I
encourage everyone to contact the
national authorities consumer protection
because they have the tools to act
against companies would not apply this
European legislation the national
authorities and to be honest we have
cases in Europe where the member states
are not active enough for even they
introduce in the legislation
some elements which are in our opinion
against the European law passenger right
and that's why on the 2nd of July we
issued efficient procedures who started
in spirit management procedures against
them Member States in order to open the
dialog and try to make them to come back
in line and respecting this European
legislation thank you and on the same
note Sarina and many more on Facebook
asked what should I do to see my rights
fulfilled if the airline I booked my
trip with is refusing to issue a refund
only offering vouchers that's exactly
what I mentioned previously the National
enforcement bodies in each member state
are the ones in charge to make sure that
the companies are respecting the right
of the passenger of or of course there
is the office of for consumer protection
European level
so your national body if you bought from
let's say from a company which is not
from your own Member State and maybe you
find the difficult to interact your
national law enforcement body in
consumer protection office can contact
the European one which will go against
that company which is let's say that you
stirred in another member state so there
are tools you have to write to your
national authorities because they are
the first who should be worried without
in charge on defending your rights thank
you very much
me I'm on Facebook could could a trip in
August or September be on the cards well
that's what that's the question does the
question I think trips are already on
cards for many destinations the European
Commission is monitoring and helping
Member States to take decision regarding
the measures they are taking to allow
travel to certain destination so I think
a lot of people already are thinking or
they booked already holidays and but I
advise you to monitor we have a site
also the European Commission you can
look on the reopen you where you can
find information on what is the
situation to a potential destination you
would choose you have to inform yourself
very well before making a decision where
to travel this summer because we cannot
predict that's unfortunate but that's
the reality we cannot predict the
epidemiological situation in each member
state it varies a lot and now with the
exiting measures in place its reopening
so we are monitoring the situation the
European Centre for Disease Control is
monitoring but decision ultimately are
made by each member state and as we can
see for example in Belgium the issue
advise each week so for this week we
know what's the situation and they
advise but next week
this might change so I I would suggest
if form very well before her traveling
because unfortunately the situation it's
a hard to predict understand we want to
appear on Twitter who just boarded a
flight and says no temperature control
before boarding is unbelievable with
this pandemic situation other mandatory
rules for Airlines regarding temperature
and masks for instance but not for
temperature because the European
Commission I mean I'm talking here not
about the transport people because it's
not directly our prerogative but we are
working with the European Center for
Disease Control with the de santé does
so the helps part of the experts of
European Commission and then with safety
agencies in transport like Aviation
Safety Agency or for a lot for in
developing and we developed these
guidelines for how to make the travel
safe the control of the temperature we
do not consider is effective so that's
why it's not part of the mandatory
mandatory measures for traveling with in
any in any mode of transportation but
I'm aware that some Member States
decided to introduce this kind of
controls so that's why it might it might
be for nyam a bit weird to see in one
member state of mandatory temperature
control and it another probably not but
it's not in at European level we have
others the wearing of the mask
disinfection of fur surfaces and what
hands sanitizing all the time as much as
possible as much as possible maintaining
the physical distance between travellers
all these things are in a practice
already I would say also in terminals
and in in aircrafts or in trains another
temperature but wear the mask
of course that was for Pierrot on
Twitter and for many others who asked
this question about safety measures many
people ask about the airlines cancelling
the flights selling tickets on certain
routes and then cancelling and after
that refusing to reimburse the
passengers we haven't read Thomas JT and
Facebook to name just a few who some
others have heard already directly from
because there are that's a new thing
there are a lot of consumers now with
restarting the the traveling air travel
this kind of situation emerged I would
say here that it's not necessarily what
I hope it's not intentional but I hope
it's or at least I can believe it at
this stage well people are still
reluctant to travel it might be that
it's also hard for a company to predict
the demand that it might be that it's
selling a ticket and then I don't know
but a flight for various reasons is
cancelled
nevertheless what is the situation
because cancelling something which you
just booked is annoying in itself so I
can understand this is also difficult
situation for passengers but
nevertheless if this is the situation of
flight is cancelled and you paid for it
you have the right of reimbursement in
seven days and again if this is this
right is not respected you should
address to your national enforcing body
to the protect our customers protection
at the office to try to
to try to have your right respected by
the company thank you very much we have
a situation somebody on Facebook asked
is that possible to travel from the
United States to Italy to meet the
girlfriend
could this be inserted in the essential
travel well I sympathize with the
situation let's say but of course it's
hard for the Commission to decide
exactly when we are talking about
essential travel we are thinking for
example for workers for doctors for
those who are supplying essential goods
I can understand that from his point of
view this is an essential travel and
it's more difficult to talk about travel
from outside European Union because
while right now the lockdown inside
European Union are sort of phased out
and with the free movement inside the
European Union the decision to open to
such countries is very tricky and it
needs to be done coordinated in a
coordinated way and I think at this
stage the recommendation does not
include accepting travel from the United
States but probably this would change
accordingly with the advice of
epidemiologists I understand and I
believe we're gonna we're gonna have
more questions on this because I so what
we received during the week a lot of
people won't want to meet I loved ones
in Europe let's see what we can do about
them moving on with the questions and I
on Facebook asked how is it possible to
plan holidays and to go to sightseeing
this summer while preventing the spread
of coronavirus by respecting the
recommendations because as we discussed
the beginning of our chat as long as we
do not have a vaccine and we know that
we'll develop a vaccine against this
virus which will take time as for each
vaccine is good to know that European
working with as many as possible labs
and companies who are developing or
researching a vaccine but it takes time
as long as we don't have a convincing or
a very effective treatment to recommend
and available for many we have to live
with the virus so travel is a virus go
to work with the virus use your bus with
the virus and that's it but if you
respect the recommendations of safety
we're a must disinfect your hands keep
the distance I think it's fair to say
that we can travel and try to have a as
normal as possible life in a certain
degree of safety thank you dragon
twitter i have been informed today that
Greece has suspended a passenger rights
legislation under EC 261 from 2004 this
means you have not covered in case of
flight cancellations and refunds will
not be offered think twice before
booking with them this is a tweet and he
asked does the Commission know about
this so he put out an information
actually Greece is one of the countries
against which we launched on 2nd of July
with an infringement procedure and the
original procedure was already mmm not
the first step because we engages member
states and try to ask them to respect
passenger rights and make sure that they
are enforcing this right through their
national authority so I really hope at
some point this will change anyway
wearing a dialogue with Member States
and trying to make sure that they are
applying this passengers right so so the
Commission knows unfortunately that this
is the situation in Greece
what happens when a citizen from a third
country X or an EU citizen who is back
from a trip in that same country X third
country X has booked a flight to an EU
Member State which refuses people from
that third country but the flight isn't
canceled well here is a shared
responsibility because in theory the
company should not allow or select a get
to a destination without checking that
the proper travel documents are in order
so that you have a visa you have your
valid passport that you are accepted in
that country so this is sort of a
responsibility of the company also not
to sell a ticket without having making
sure that but the other hand the
responsibility relies on the travel
himself or herself because you have to
check very well which are the conditions
to your destinations because then and
especially if you are coming from a
third country you are not covered by
many of very high-end protection for
passengers rights we have in Europe and
so we're gonna take just a short break
from the holidays and passenger rights
because we have live question from
Facebook on the recently adopted
mobility package one where is the
European Commission with the impact
assessment for the return of the truck
and the capital restrictions well so
exactly there are two topics that are
going to be two studies we had a very
transparent procedure to select a
contractor which was go who is going to
make these studies for the Commission we
had the phase of establishing the
questions well this was a consultation
or there is a consultation process with
stakeholders to frame the subject
exactly what kind of data do we need in
order to reach valid conclusions so this
is the stage we are going to open also a
wider consultation
we are gathering data so we are hoping
that by here I don't know let's say for
the last phase maybe and the focused
five weeks so somewhere at the beginning
of October we'll have the data gathered
and then we can put forward that I hope
by the end of the year and analysis of
this data concerning the return of the
truck and kibosh thank you very much way
back to holidays and we talked about
airports I'm not gonna name a specific
airport but Richard on facebook says
have you checked some of the European
airports they are filthy and non - clean
or sanitize after the person has left
the table I'm sure this is the case in
many places what we are doing we issued
guidelines for the airports we are in
peril organize the flows and sanitizing
and measures of security inside the
airport so we have guidelines for them
we have a program of several airports
pilot programs through the European
agency for safety in aviation NASA where
the answer is going actually in it's
involving itself in the organization of
an airport in order to make sure these
kind of measures are implemented those
are several airports and we are in
indirect contact and discussion with the
association of the European airports to
see what are the issues they are facing
but I have seen more pictures in some
places where things are going very well
and some places where things are going
terribly bad so it depends also a lot on
the national authorities because they
are the first to make sure that the
airports are respecting the guidance in
what measures they should implement for
the safety of travelers thank you very
much
Philip on Facebook is an airline
entitled to ask your reason for travel
if you have all the correct track
documents no no I don't think so I don't
think so it might be the reason to
travel it might be for commercial
purposes hmm when we when they tick a
box and say are you traveling for
pleasure for a business for that's it
might be also sort of a commercial basis
it might be that someone might want to
determine if you are an essential
traveler as I said if you are a doctor
going to volunteer or help or transport
to medicine or something then of course
you you might be allowed in a country
which otherwise does not allow allow
travelers coming from a certain
destination so it might be the case but
or else I don't see why a company would
ask why you are travelling instead okay
we nearing the end of this live chat in
English we must inform the audience that
we will continue in Romania after a
short break but I have one last question
you have answered it before but it's
it's pretty worth repeating again the
answer what is the deadline for
reimbursing passengers whose flights
were cancelled according to the law 7
days 7 days but Commissioner the the
work continued here in Brussels the
European Commission I'm sure this summer
you'll take the holiday I wish you a
nice holiday and to all our viewers who
have watched us until now all the best
I'm joining you this wishes all the best
bye
you